here we will use the short match
functionality in the UCSC genome browser
to find a short sequence motif within
our content before we get started go to
the genome browser gateway page and
select the dimalanta gaster genome and
the August 2014
BD GP release 6 plus is o1 mt / DM 6
assembly enter CHR - R :
18 million eight hundred sixty seven
thousand three hundred fifty through
eighteen million eight hundred sixty
seven thousand four hundred thirty into
the search term field and click Submit
this region contains the transcription
start site of the Drosophila
melanogaster DP TB Jean short match can
be used to search for short sequences
between two and thirty bases long for
this example we will use short match to
search for the initiator motif or INR
the INR is a motif that is associated
with the RNA polymerase two core
promoter and previous studies suggest
that transcription factor to D or tf2d
binds specifically to this motif the INR
motif when found typically begins two
bases upstream of the transcription
start site though the location of the
motif can vary by a few bases the
consensus sequence for the INR motif in
drosophila is six spaces long running in
the same orientation as the gene to use
short match locate the mapping and
sequencing tracks section within the
genome browser and click on the short
match link change the display mode field
to pack and type TCA kty into the short
two through 30 base sequence field notes
that TCA kty is the consensus sequence
for the INR in drosophila k represents
kitto either guanine or thymine and y
represents perimeter either cytosine or
thymine
after changing the display mode and
typing in the consensus sequence click
Submit
you will see perfect matches to the
short sequence that you typed appear as
black bars within the browser window the
label next to the black bar describes
the orientation and the start position
of the motif match in this case the INR
motif is located three nucleotides
downstream of the annotated
transcription start site of DP TB at 18
million 867,000 394 in the positive
orientation